good afternoon everyone and thank you
guys for having me my name is Ben and I
am NOT from North Carolina I'm from
Washington DC where my primary job is
actually at the University of Maryland
in the computer science department but
I'm here today representing a district
data labs which in DC is an open source
collaborative there are you know
probably 20-30 people who are involved
in the organization that work on open
source projects and so today I want to
talk about a few of those projects and
do something a little different take off
the computer science hat that I usually
wear and start thinking about the
analytics hat you know when we develop
software we're developing it usually for
analytics users and to sort of think
about how we can combine you know
computer science you know graph theory
graph analysis and graph databases or
data structures with a more analytical
focus particularly looking at time
series trend analysis and prediction so
you know these are just some thoughts
from from the work that we've been doing
and the research that we've been looking
at and I hope that you guys enjoying it
just one note most of the software that
I present here I is going to be you know
developed by ddl things like Bailey and
minky they're all in github they're all
open source so you know I unfortunate i
didn't get links into the presentation
but please you know tweet at us let us
know if you're interested in these
things but I also chose to use for the
graph library I chose to use graph tool
which i think is sort of a lesser-known
you know almost everyone knows about
network x but graph tool is this sort of
it's a c++ implementation of a lot of
libraries with a python interface and
it's hugely powerful and also a giant
pain in the butt so force myself to
grapple with that so we could explore
know maybe using this tool and all the
code is from from graph tool that you'll
see in the presentation today so the
question I want to ask is which are
graphs effective for analytics right I'm
a computer scientist and we are told
old at least in computer science that
graphs are the sort of is very useful
data structure and you can formulate
algorithms as grass and you can sort of
think about traversals when we teach
computer science 131 at the University
of Maryland right all these
undergraduates are learning to program
and their first implementations are
Dijkstra's algorithm in the bellman-ford
algorithm so like right out of the gate
their programming graft style
computations and they sort of invade the
world but we started looking at the
analytics you know a new question came
up like should we use graphs at all when
perhaps linear algebra implementations
or machine learning or other statistical
styles of analysis are more sort of
mainstream particularly for things like
time series analysis so I hope to
explore that with you guys today I so
you know just actually I out of
curiosity who here does use graphs for
analysis okay so that looked like a
small sample maybe ten percent and and
you know even as we're starting to look
at this presentation the thing that I've
realized is is it's actually not that
straightforward even though it's a
simple sort of thing to get into it
really does have a lot of different
types of implications so when I think
about graphs and when I teach graphs I
usually present two facets right graphs
are good for either algorithmic
performance particularly for machine
learning and the reason that they're
good for algorithms is because they have
very simple or understandable
implementations and when you have
something that's very easy to understand
you can optimize it and you can do more
complex things you know leveraging that
simplicity to great advantage the other
key point here and I think this is why
grass exists in computer science is that
graphs are natively parallelizable right
so you can distribute them using you
know gas gather analyze scatter you can
bundle nodes and their neighborhoods and
reduce fashion you know there are many
different distributed computing
libraries like graphics and freckle and
things for for doing large-scale
computation on graphs so you know at
sort of all levels we think about that
performance benefit but then on the
other side graphs are also very useful
for visual analytics right humans are
well trained to think about
interconnection structures because we
are are social creatures and we can
immediately recognize and get insights
from from very simple graphs right there
immediately understandable and and they
actually prevent provide a mechanism for
interaction that's not native to other
types of visualization you know when you
see a graph the first thing you want to
do is touch it move it and sort of see
what's changing and how things are being
connected and dragged around the screen
and I think for that reason grass have
played a large role in data storytelling
Dave narratives Mike Bostock is
popularized them at the New York Times
and other places so we have these sort
of like two ideas a graph should be very
useful so what can you do with graphs
what what types of analyses can you do
and you know I think about things in
terms of for sort of primary classes of
computation the first is computation
right or construction that rather can we
build a graph can we build a graph out
of another graph or is there the
possibility given some constraints that
you can organize nodes and their
relationships together in a meaningful
way once you've constructed it you can
start asking questions like are is there
a formal structure to this graph is a
bipartite graph dusick lyssa tease
exists is it fully connected not
connected at all and so even just the
active building or constructing a graph
as an analytic process if we're talking
about statistics today maybe a
statistical analysis so once you get in
what you have a graph you want to start
counting things start a new Marie ting
things particularly degree how connected
are these vertices right how many edges
are there right do we see bundles or
clusters or triangles right what are the
things that we can count in this graph
and perform other types of statistical
analysis
on and that style of enumeration leads
to most machine learning implementations
particularly when you think about graphs
things like page rank and even sort of
Bayesian network analysis or probability
mechanisms you can ask about existence
right is there a minimum spanning tree
what is the shortest path is there a
collection of vertices that meets this
criteria and you know when you start
thinking about that you can actually
start to think well maybe there are
structured style queries that we can
perform on graphs and in fact there are
a lot of attempts at your cipher data
log even as source equal like query
languages to say you know hey can we do
something with graphs and a more
structured or declarative fashion but
whereas that's the end right some table
or some result is the end of an
existence query in a structured domain
with grass you can also start to think
about optimization right what's the
shortest what's the longest what's the
minimum what's the fastest and you can
start to develop you know iterative
approaches to understanding these things
so what are you actually doing the
primary method of computation is
traversal right you think about where
you start and where you're going how you
cross these edges and I think that that
might be the first place where we have
to do a shift right instead of selecting
or gathering we have to think about
moving right and you know sort of like
when you're on a terminal for the first
time you have to think well where am I
one of my colleagues mentioned that this
figure sort of looks like a geographic
map rate of maybe road network or
something like that and it's a really
good thing to have in your head because
every one of those four classes all of
the algorithms that are inside of those
classes of graph analysis are
implemented as traversals right you
collect edges and then you move out or
collect nodes and you move out their
outgoing edges and keep going through so
if you want to traverse on something we
do need some sort of model right some
graph model and the one that I'm going
to whoops out of order slide there the
one I'm going to talk about today is the
property graph model so property gran
are separate from adjacency lists and
other style graphs that you might have
and I think they're important for data
scientists because property graphs are
really the only graph model that
actually embed data that's usable inside
of them so property graph thinks about
all structural elements right and all
structural elements can have associated
key value pairs and they also all have
to have a unique ID associated with them
I'm using that term structural element I
deliberately vague for a reason because
once you start to see once we start
adding dynamics once you start adding
change you know what is a structure
becomes very important so just a list a
few the graph itself is a structure
right whether it is the complete graph
or a sub graph or some picture at tie a
piece of time the graph should be able
to have key value properties associated
with it and then that structure itself
is an object that contains both vertices
and edges very specific set of vertices
and edges a graph might be the result of
a query right you might think of it that
way I've been using these terms
hopefully I guys are familiar at least a
little bit with vertices vertices are
objects that have incoming and outgoing
edges and again that deliberately vague
sort of description gives us the
opportunity to model a lot of things as
vertices not just entities or things
right they are just simply structures
that have connectivity associated with
them and what are the connections those
things are edges edges are simply things
with a source and a target right in
incoming or an outgoing edge they can be
directed or undirected but they connect
vertices in particular so you know as
you can see here on this sort of
property graph this demonstrates the
Olympics we have several different types
of nodes we have country nodes we have
athlete's nodes we have event nodes we
even have the Olympics itself as a
vertex here the you know you can sort of
think if this is a graph of the 2016
olympics right but there are other
Olympics so you know even just coming up
with some graph
model to show you that doesn't even
necessarily has time in it my in bed
time right this is a single graph that
doesn't represent the entirety of the
Olympics vertices have types right so if
we're going to start to do multi-domain
modeling you're gonna have to have a
type edges have labels and potentially
also weights right but these are very
rich data structures and they allow us
to model time you know I think very
easily and just to go back to this quote
from marco rodriguez you know Marco is
the contributor to Apache tinker pop and
datastax he does a lot of work with
graphs and and I would call him a graph
evangelist right it really pushes the
use of graphs in every day commuting
computing and data analytics but he
summarizes a sort of two elements
algorithmic performance and visual
analytics as you know graph technologies
ease modeling in the domain right
because you know we're good we're good
at coming up with inter connection
structions but that modeling itself
isn't enough right the ability to model
something isn't you know you know if you
have a weak model it's not going to get
you very far so what graphs also do is
they ease the speed and simplicity of
the types of queries that you're going
to to ask of them and so we want to
investigate that very specifically with
time today right is that actually true
can we get away with more than just
having a graph model and so we should
ask ourselves in this property graph you
know data structure that we have how do
we model time where do we put time in
this so I want to start with you know
where is the time in a relational
database right I've already sort of made
this parallel to structured queries and
the sort of first step in analytics
where we try to materialize some table
some list of tuples that we can start to
perform work on so if you're going to
model data in a relational database
particularly if it's normalized you're
going to usually think of entity
relationship diagrams right so great we
have a graph right off the bat and you
know when you think about entities
entities usually have descriptive time
elements right their dates or times
they're usually encoded as a timestamp
with time zone if you have a Postgres
database
and those things change right and a
datetime the descriptive date time will
change on an entity using it like a
transaction will update those records if
you want to encode a series right you
want to save history or think about how
things change over time you need to
actually create a special type of entity
called an event events are tables that
are optimized for inserts right you
write to them you don't modify them and
you know for that reason there's been a
lot of work in time series databases
specifically like in flux DB and a few
others where they're trying to you know
create these sort of really read through
three put data databases that can handle
a lot of event encoding events though
themselves are going to be discreet
right they're going to have if they have
a single time step they just represent a
single point in time and if you have two
time steps and maybe you can represent
an interval but you can't encode time on
a single relationship right you can
encode a foreign key with time and if
you want to do that you have to create
some sort of intermediate table right a
relational table which we usually sort
of think up for many too many type
relationships not one too many or even
one to one type relationship so even as
we start thinking about this from the
relational perspective we're already
sort of bogged down in a lot of details
that hopefully you guys can see
immediately we get away from with the
property graph model just as sort of a
side note if any of you guys have a
relational database it has this kind of
data I would encourage you to think
about graph gin another open source tool
that can extract graphs out of
relational databases and do in memory
graph computations which is a pretty
neat tool okay so back to the property
graph model we were going to want to
embed time as a property right that
seems pretty clear and where time gets
embedded is at any particular structure
right any key value pair and you can
start to see that there are a lot of
different types of embedded time so here
across the top we have a couple of these
sort of object these blocks with ABC
having last seen descriptive time on
them they have a duration
on the edge associated with these event
nodes we have an ordinal time
relationship here so you can see that
you know this these blue events proceed
and so even though there's no specific
time encoded you have a time
relationship you have things like timers
durations time since elapsed you know
you even have this sort of waiting for
thing there the the top right right you
have a time that has not yet occurred or
future time and one of the thoughts is
well maybe we can encode predictions or
forecasts as structural elements right
associate them with the probability or
maybe a slope or something that we can
use and then as time progresses we can
evaluate very quickly we can query which
trends are actually happening and in
real time restructure our traversals
according to the predictions that we're
making as we're delivering output to our
applications I personally you know I did
that a lot with recommender systems
where we would encode recommendations as
sort of predicted types of events they
would be embedded in the queries and
displayed and you know we would use
clickstream data to reinforce that and
to refresh the predictions using triadic
closures or other triangle relationships
and so you know there's some graph
things right these things are native to
graphs you can't do them in other types
of domains that you get for free and
these types of models and you know the
other thing I'm hoping to demonstrate
both with this model and the Olympics
model is that these multi domain right
where we have these vertices of
different types and they're all sort of
co-mingled in the same graph that's
actually going to be the path forward
that's what we're going to have to do in
order to look at dynamics so once we
have time as a property I think we all
understand the time necessarily modifies
traversal right it affects our queries
and so maybe we can check off the yes
this does speed up our query box because
rather than having to materialize some
sort of time on demand and evaluated
against some criteria we simply don't
traverse that link and maybe we
made a whole path of computation by by
using time to balance reversal so
traversals can exclude paths that are
two recent or two old you can actually
wait by time so if you want to minimize
time you can traverse if you have
options about past achievers you can
choose the minimum time or you can
choose minimum spanning trees that have
the lowest amount of time with them and
like I said before you can also add
tentative or future times in order to
create links that didn't exist before so
here's a quick example this is an email
inbox network and so here I didn't
include the link unfortunately but this
is one of the first projects that one
introduced and is called tribe so tribe
is a Python tool that will extract a
graph from an email mbox right so
something you can export out of apple
mail or out of Google and so this
particular graph is a multi graph where
each vertex is going to be an email
address right or an inbox and the link
the edge is going to be unnie mail right
and the properties are sent or and the
subject right and it's a multi graph
because it's you know two email
addresses can have many emails between
them so i exported mine and i got 6,000
174 email addresses that are in my inbox
I don't respond to that many people so
I'm 100-percent sure where that came
from but 343,000 emails right that's how
many emails are in this graph and each
of those emails has an average degree of
about 111 right so apparently these are
people that I communicate with fairly
often as I'm working so that's too many
right here is the hierarchical edge
bundling version of that graph so you
can see that edges are collected
together so regions of color are a
single email address and the edges are
the emails that are going across to
other email addresses and you know while
this kind of looks neat I'm not sure you
could really make too much
interpretation right or get too much
insight off of this graph so here's the
first place we're going to introduce
some graph to a code graph tool creates
sub graphs by using views right so
you're going to instantiate a view which
is a highly optimized layer on top of
the original graph
that doesn't actually remove any data
structure under the hood including
properties and other things so what I've
done is I've created these filtering
functions where you can supply before or
after and the graph and what it's going
to do is it's going to return a closure
a function that takes an edge and
returns true or false whether that edge
belongs in the view or not so here by
specifying before or after this inner
function filters emails based on when
they were sent another one that I've
included on this slide that we're going
to use in the here shortly as a degree
filter right so excluding nodes where
who haven't sent a certain number of
emails right so we could exclude anyone
whose cell s than five emails or we can
even create filters like there has to be
two-way communication so anytime I
receive an email but I don't respond
exclude those types of nodes right and
this sub graphing that we're going to be
doing sort of the constant thing that
you're doing with these types of
analytics right it's almost like you
know predicates saan the sequel clause
you have to do them or else you can't
really understand or aggregate
meaningfully so once we apply these
things and you can see here's the view
right down here this graph view that's
taking the edge filter and the degree
filter and we move down from 6,000
vertices to about 853 simply by
filtering on all the emails that have
occurred between you know 9am on August
first and 5pm on august 31st so this is
a month of emails and you can see that
you know the edge bundling gets far
simpler to the fact to the point where
you can even see the intermediate nodes
right so those dots in the middle are
root nodes that have you know their
control points where there's sort of
critical mass of communication so in
this case most of those nodes are my
various emails like my Georgetown email
or my ddl email or my bank freecom email
and the friends and family are also in
the middle there so at this point we now
have the ability to conduct insights
okay so that's all great and now we sort
understand how to get time into graphs
but what we actually haven't done is do
anything with dynamics right which is
the title of this presentation so what
are dynamics dynamics means change and
there are two methods to encode change
in the graph the first is to deliberate
include time as a structure take it away
from this property model and put it in
as a specific element and the second is
to create a new data structure which if
you look at the math for this is called
a it's a capital gamma right capital G
dynamic graph which is not just a single
graph of vertices and edges but it's
actually an ordered series of graphs
that increase in order of time so the
first thing that we have to then think
about is if we're going to construct
either static or dynamic graphs in this
fashion we have to I mean you know I
actually I can't think of a way that we
could get away with you know not doing
some sort of discrete time right we need
independent time steps we need to
identify this is one time region and
this is another and so you know we can
think of that in two ways the first way
that we can think of that is as
intervals right so we have specified
intervals of time and intervals are
independent that can be fixed length
right so an interval of an hour or they
can be variable length right so
sequences of time where things are
happening inside of events but if you
don't do that you're going to have to
pick some specific granularity for the
time steps you have either roll up or
drill down you know all the way from
like let's say years but I suppose if
you have a really long graph you can go
higher than yours but going from years
down to minutes or you know sort of
depending on how fine timestamps you
have even down to seconds or
milliseconds or something like that and
you have to a great all of your time
stamps at one level at one hierarchy
this creates an interesting opportunity
that is for a future work that we
haven't explored and that's watching how
grass change as we go up and down this
hierarchy and so if anyone's interested
in that they should look at that but for
for this purpose we're going to actually
look at the week right so we're going to
aggregate everything on weak so weak 0
is you know the week starting January
first and then week 1 and week 2 and so
forth all the way up to a week 52 so
here is the first mechanism extracting
time as an independent element and
anytime you see an edge with a property
on it that edge can simply
come a two edges with a vertex in the
middle right and that vertex becomes the
property so that's a very typical way of
expanding or even collapsing graphs
right you can collapse intermediate
nodes into single edges and get
different levels of granularity there so
here you know the week is going to be
these blue vertices and you can start to
see the different types of nodes that
are connected to that and what should
immediately jump out you at you here is
the sort of linear ordering of events
ordered by the alphabet in order to make
that more clear so ABCD happened before
jkl right and the layout here sort of
specifies time from you know left to
right as as we might expect and we can
start to see things like be e and h are
prerequisites to F right they have to
happen before F and that you know this
entire system might not work without a
and C kicking it off right bad these are
things that are generating time steps to
us method number one member to yes so I
mean it depends on the label I haven't
specified here oh sorry the question was
I do a and C happen before or
concurrently oh so the OIC so the first
the two times that are over each other
yeah I haven't really specified the
relationship between those two times
it's an interesting question yeah
absolutely oh but I mean and these are
exactly the types of questions that you
want these graphs to invoke right is
there concurrent behavior here is there
some other behavior that we can see and
investigate deeply so I'm glad that like
that's the first thing that came to mind
the other sort of stuff that we can take
is to grab subgraphs over time and then
you know at each period look at how the
sub graphs changes and so what you
should note about this is that you know
at each time step the edges are changing
the number of vertices are changing
right so you know we get F in time stamp
too we lose both a and F and time step 3
and here you can sort of really start to
see the structure of the graph changing
over time although you lose and for
right it's hard to know what the
relationship is between time t1 and time
t3 without having that intermediate step
in between so I know I'm going a little
long here so I want to introduce this
key phrases over time work that we did
to investigate this topic so another two
projects the ddl is working on are
called baleen and minky baleen is an RSS
ingestion tool that just every hour
downloads about 400 RSS feeds and grabs
all of the HTML data from the web stores
it in a [ __ ] database so far we've
collected over 600,000 documents has
been running since March third and you
know I sort of maybe said something to
the effect of like oh six hundred
thousand documents 60 gigabytes that's
not that big because I'm used to working
on much larger things but it's funny
once you actually start to grapple with
this on like your single machine without
spark or something like that it does
feel pretty big minky is a NLP
pre-processing a tool that's
specifically meant for preparing natural
language corpora for machine learning so
producing document vectors and things
like that and so what it does or what
it's done on our behalf is it's
extracted a graph of key phrases
weighted by their tf-idf their team term
frequency inverse document frequency
score I think it's important to note
that actually a graph representation is
often the final product of a natural
language analysis especially if you're
doing something like named entity
recognition entailment reference
resolution things like that a graph data
structure gives you sort of an easy
ability to analyze or figure out what's
happening in the language so the data
model that we put together has four
types of nodes categories so this going
to be things like politics news data
science feeds those are the the
collection of documents that were
downloading over time the document
itself which is actually what contains
the timestamp of interest the
publication date of that article and
then we have all of these key phrases
that are associated with it if you see
the first version of this on the
complete corpus got us a graph of 2.6
million nodes and forty six point nine
million edges which is about 20
gigabytes in memory I which is too much
for this machine so we sample
down to about 139,000 nodes and 257,000
vertices and hopefully figure out that
it's still pretty tough to work on that
like any good data product or data
analysis we went through the you know
that was the ingestion phase and then we
had to go through the wrangling phase so
one thing that we did here was to filter
again create the sub graph of these high
degree notes if you guys remember that
degree filter that I presented earlier
here we say that the node has to have
four or more connections or edges in
order to be allowed into our graph and
that kind of makes sense because we're
eliminating you know hey packs hey taxes
or other phrases that may not have you
know too much impact or weight on the
things that we're looking at this if you
guys aren't used to graph analytics this
is sort of the first thing that you
should do with your grass and that's to
make sure that you have a power laws
degree distribution which we do have
because that means that you you're
heading towards like a small worlds
graph you're heading towards a graph
that has clusters and sort of meaningful
it's not just a fully connected graph
that you really can't do much on and
then also looking at the distribution of
your vertex types right you should sort
of think you know what what is happening
here and what do we actually have in the
graph and then so the last piece of the
data wrangling is again this idea of the
ego filter right and this is going to
come up in both the static and the
dynamic analysis right we have to
somehow be able to pull out graphs or
specific graphs for specific vertices so
again this is another graph tool
filtering mechanism where we create a
function that returns a closure in this
case we specify the vertex that we want
to be the ego the center of the network
and a number of hops out that we want to
collect nodes for our sub graph on and
then we use the shortest distance
between the ego and that vertex and
that's what we do compared to the number
of hops to determine inclusion and so
you can see that if you take a single
document the title of this document is
villanova outs iowa exercises second
round demons to reach sweet 16 you can
create an ego graph from that document
and look at its key phrases specifically
so here are things like NCAA tournament
Super Bowl
red vertex is its category this is in
the news category not the sports
category reaction moment pull and so you
can start to get a feel for what's
inside your graph and then the sort of
smaller views what the whole graph looks
like that's fairly unreadable yes so the
I'll get into that actually that's the
next topic here so well what kinds of
analytics like graph specific analytics
can we do and you know the nodes are all
different sizes which was the question
how can we take a look at that and so
the first thing that I think you want
start to look at is what is the
centrality was the centrality of time
here so in order to do the static graph
time is a structure style analysis we
have to extract at a certain level right
this week level and you can see that the
extraction here is simple and this is a
lot of code I just want to point out
that we're using this DT is 0 calendar
function over here to get out the week
number so that's that aggregation
looking at that cut and then here we're
just doing traversals right we're just
looking for the neighbors and selecting
nodes specifically for those neighbors
there are several types of sensuality
measures and so just to highlight for
you can think about things like degree
centrality right you know the more
connections a note has the more
important it has which is in contrast
between the centrality between the
centrality as well if given all the
shortest paths from all nodes to all
other nodes which nodes sit in the
middle of the most paths and that's a
very different idea than I ghen vector
centrality or pagerank sexuality or cat
centrality which think well you know
it's not just about you it's about you
being connected to other important nodes
you know what I you know hopefully you
can observe here is that the color is is
a scale color continuous color that the
darker it is the more important that
note is and the different centrality
measures give you different metrics and
the questions that we want to start to
ask is well how important are our time
structures also how important are our
key phrases related to these time
structures so just to take a little cut
here and I really couldn't figure out a
good way to
visualize this but to that graph I've
applied both between the centrality and
cat centrality and then rank them and so
you can see we have both weeks and
phrases right because they're both
vertices in the graph so week 40 is more
between than week 2 which is more
between than week 45 which could sort of
show that these weeks have more terms
that are sort of more global whereas we
have a different ordering of weeks when
you look at the the cat centrality then
when you start to look at the terms
themselves in there between this you can
start to see things like turnout
Democratic undocumented immigrants big
issue in week 45 verses in week 1 rows
local pastry dessert lemon but you start
to see like the feels like there's
actually sort of something connecting
things here in the cast centrality you
can see citizen natholi finance big
efficiency sweet party delegate Twitter
comment right so you know these
centrality measures these things that we
think of as graph only type things are
allowing us to do an investigation that
we couldn't have otherwise and fairly
simple like slide level code which is a
good thing so maybe maybe graphs are
something that we can use to perform
analytics what about dynamics can we
look at the change over time well to do
that you have to create sequences of
time ordered sub graphs so here is week
to week for week five what happened to
week three it turns out that the server
crashed on week three and so we lost all
the documents from week three or at
least I didn't get anything but the
thing to note here is that the vertices
are sized by their centrality in this
case between the sensuality and they're
sized globally so they're not sized
relative to the time their size relative
to all time so what you can start to
observe is that we too has fewer more
central key phrases as opposed to week 4
which has way more less central key
phrases and this is changing this is
fluctuating so there's a new cycle
there's a there's something happening
that's changing the topics over time
right we four we're talking about things
we always talk about we three we're
talking about things that we rarely talk
about but are really important and of
course you can animate this and graph
tool actually has an animation function
which I'll display here um and you can
start to see things so I just want to
point out a couple things since I'm
running out of time for animation so as
much as possible you want to fix both
vertex and edge positions they shouldn't
move transitions should be eased so fade
in fade out you want to sort see what's
coming and see what's leaving the only
change in animation should be time right
you don't want to change anything else
you want to change centrality but you
can animate any sort of property but it
should all be related to flow and
moreover you should give the user
control to explore change now this isn't
really available in Python right so a
graph tool uses gtk windows so you can
forgive interactivity you might think
there's interactivity with Jupiter
notebooks or something like that but
with the size of these graphs you can
see that you're already in a huge
performance train as it is so just to
wrap up I want to conclude with some
thoughts about network visualization
sort of a contrast to how hard this
might be you know the the most important
thing and hopefully what you're seeing
is that layout and positioning is by far
the most important and layout precludes
you from having many nodes in your graph
so you need to create sub graphs this is
from Lane Harrison and she talks about
all these properties of graphs that you
can change you can add elements to
particularly visual properties and the
reason I bring them up is because all of
these things are available in raft well
you can change the vertex shape color
size even give the PI notes for edges
you can change the color size direction
so these tools are available to you but
the question is you know is it enough
this is the complete key phrase graph
ordered by week there's not a whole lot
of understanding that you can do in
these things and so you need to work on
it it needs to be interactive you need
to have a tool that you can go back and
forth and specify different levels and
modify it and with that I will leave you
with this idea of visual analysis and
graphs being essential for a visual
analysis where there's a connection
between the human and the analytical
procedures
and challenge you guys to all go and
look specifically how you can create
interaction inside of your analytics
with the mantra overview first zoom and
filter details and demand and if you can
do that I think that time and the
dynamics of grass will become some a
very powerful tool that you can use in
your analytics tool kits